cutting-edge effects technology isn't
always used to create cool explosions
and giant robots release nearly 30 years
after the original film Tron Legacy is a
computerized adventure packed with light
cycles and Daft Punk music most
importantly this 2010 Disney film gave
audiences double the dude Jeff Bridges
returned to the Tron universe as two
separate characters
first there's the heroic Kevin Flynn who
looks exactly like the older actor but
then there's clue the artificial
intelligence gone Rowe and while he was
played by a man in his 60s this evil
computer program looks more or less like
Bridges did back in the eighties VFX
supervisor Erik Barba oversaw the
transformation he achieved it with a
four camera head mounted system that
bridges wore on the set to get a
floating 3d point cloud of his face the
effect may look a little computery but
that's okay because after all glue is a
computer program the tragic death of
Paul Walker in 2013 sent a massive
shockwave through the Fast and Furious
community after all this is a franchise
about family and both Walker and his
character of Brian O'Connor were super
important to a whole lot of people his
death had serious implications for the
production of Furious 7 as the actor
died during filming fortunately wet a
digital was able to save the day and
preserve Walker's legacy for Fast &
Furious fans around the world the folks
at Wetty digitally created a whopping
350 shots of Walker doing everything
from jumping skyscrapers to standing in
a lineup with the rest of his crew
additionally Walker's brothers caleb and
cody and actor John Brotherton gave
motion capture performances that wedding
used to recreate Brian thanks to their
incredible work he got to ride with his
family one last time when Kevin Spacey
was accused by multiple victims of
sexual assault director Ridley Scott
made one of the gutsiest decisions in
Hollywood history Spacey and Scott had
recently finished working on all the
money in the world when the scandal
broke unwilling to keep Spacey in the
film Scott replaced the actor with
Christopher Plummer reshooting every
scene featuring Spacey's character
stingy billionaire jay paul Getty it was
an unprecedented move and it costs ten
million dollars to exercise Spacey from
the film most of these scenes were done
practically with other actors on actual
sets but there is one quick moment in
which Scott resorted to some digital
trickery we're seeing in which get egos
to Jordan it was
I'm practical to go all the way back to
the Middle East so plumber was shot in
front of a green screen and after the
special effects proved digitally erased
Spacey they just slid plumber right into
place
2017 s Blade Runner 20 49 was a
beautiful follow-up to the original 1982
Blade Runner it saw the return of
Harrison Ford as Rick Deckard but he
wasn't the only original cast member to
come back during one key scene the aging
Deckard is confronted by a ghost from
his past
it's Rachel the replicant he fell in
love with in the first film only this
isn't the Rachel that Deckard remembers
that Rachel is dead this is a new shiny
one created solely to tempt Decker to
the dark side and this isn't exactly the
actress we remember either in order to
th Sean young by over 30 years the
moving picture company analyzed photos
of her studied scenes from the first
film and even checked out Young's other
performances from around the same era
they also photographed young with a
special device that captured her
likeness from multiple angles with all
these references they were able to
create a CGI face that they could then
layer onto a body double who shot the
scene with Ford with young standing by
as an adviser
unlike many digital creations the Rachel
of 2049 looks incredibly lifelike which
is kind of perfect for a movie that
wonders what makes us human in this film
about adult friends playing a game of
tag for years and years Jeremy Renner is
an uncatchable man he's been evading his
buddies by moving like an Olympic
athlete and dodging outstretched hands
like he's in the matrix during one of
these escape scenes Renner jumped on top
of a huge stack of chairs which resulted
in disaster when the rigging that held
the chairs in place snapped and sent him
tumbling when Renner got up he realized
he'd broken both his arms as he
explained to Entertainment Weekly he
could still move his limbs up and down
kind of like a robot so he didn't leave
too much digital assistance however
there is one moment when the VFX crew
had to create a completely CG arm and
it's in the very scene where his stunt
went wrong
specifically when he tosses a donut at
Ed Helms needless to say were
legitimately impressed that Renner could
deal with all that pain and continue
filming
[Music]